[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys anna welcome back to the leia
hill pen show this is a special so i'm
really excited to announce that i'm
doing an ama with block fi
so joining me today on behalf of
blockbuy is shane
mullen shane great to have you how are
you doing today hey leah i'm doing great
thanks for having me
yeah it's a pleasure i'm super excited
um because we had celsius on
um a couple weeks ago so i think it's
only right to have you guys on um
and kind of just provide the audience
with as much information
as possible about the best places they
can go
to earn interest on their crypto so are
you ready sounds sounds great
okay great so for those that don't know
anything about blockfy
um just tell us about it how did you get
started um and also where does the name
come from it's quite an interesting one
yeah it's a couple really great
questions leia so um
starting with kind of the evolution of
the business
back in 2017 zac prince our co-founder
bought a ton of bitcoin had a
substantial
you know ethereum litecoin a couple
other positions and
with the meteoric rise of the price of
bitcoin rather than wanting to sell his
position and earn liquidity in that
capacity
he was looking for an alternative way to
unlock liquidity on his assets
so what's the best way to unlock
liquidity on a pool of assets well
traditionally in the equity markets you
can margin lend and borrow against the
value of your portfolio so zach went out
to the bunch of banks that he had
known and a bunch of fintechs and was
looking for liquidity or a loan
backed by his bitcoin uh and it didn't
exist
and that was the impetus for the
business right creating uh crypto backed
loans
uh collateralized by the
cryptocurrencies that we support today
um that business grew really quickly in
2017 2018
uh and then shortly thereafter zach and
flory who's our other co-founder
realized that
not only is lending which is one
financial service
uh within you know the broader kind of
fintech ecosystem available or
should be available for crypto investors
but other financial services products
should be available as well
right things like an interest account
where you can earn yield on your crypto
things like trading or buying and
selling things like credit
uh and the list goes on uh and so the
business today if you fast forward has
evolved into a full suite financial
services
system platform for the crypto investor
um and the name
funny enough it's uh
i want to say and zack's probably going
to say you're wrong on this one but
i want to say it's a play on sofi right
so far is social
finance block fi is blockchain finance
so block fi
is what it's short for okay interesting
so
i guess you know you guys wanted to
provide something different
um and like you said you interest is
obviously a huge one for you guys and
something that i always tend to ask
um because it's something that i can't
even myself wrap my head around is the
interest right
so you know interest levels are
basically
interest rates are basically flat right
i mean particularly in the uk we saw
negative interest rates across europe
um so when i try and tell my friends
actually my brother is a fantastic
example you know i'm turning around and
i'm like
you need to sign up with these accounts
you can get all this interest
it's really hard to explain where this
comes from and how you're able to do
that
if traditional banks aren't able to do
that so i actually
have i think i think i deposited like
500 or something with you guys
um in usdc and i get up to 8.6 percent
interest
so how on earth are you doing this yeah
it's a great question so you know
similar to the way that a bank
operates with its deposits right where
it will take
any of our dollars that we put into a
checking account and then repurpose and
lend them out to institutional clients
we do the exact same thing with
cryptocurrency so if you put your usdc
or your gusd or bitcoin ethereum into a
block by interest account we are
actually lending that those funds out to
institutional counterparties
who are borrowing against or borrowing
from block fi
at you know rates that are meaningful uh
where we're able to pass down some of
that yield onto our
uh depositors um which would be our
retail clients like yourself
um so through our massive
today which has grown probably 5x since
i started five months ago
uh institutional desk we're able to
capture very significant yields in a
very sustainable way
okay so this question is kind of just
off the top of my head why don't you
think banks are doing this if it's so
simple if it's so easy and you know
plenty of crypto companies are doing it
what's the problem
oh man i have a long long laundry list
of items
why that's not the case but i think just
in general look like
at the end of the day we're still very
early innings in what we're doing here
within the crypto space
um there aren't many institutional
lenders uh
because institutional lenders have not
been in the space long enough to
understand
some of the risks associated or how to
underwrite or how to properly
manage a large portfolio of crypto
assets
and i think banks in general right don't
and
will not in the short term be able to
support
some of the financial services type
products that we can support today
because
they just simply don't understand how
these assets work and they do not have
the
rules and and systems built to support
the scale and the speed in which
you need to operate in this environment
so i think you'll start to see banks
slowly enter into space more in the form
of a custody
like relationship but when we talk about
customer facing financial services
products and institutional facing
financial services products i think it's
going to take a while
i think you know you mentioned banks
getting into the space as you know
custodians and
and i think that's so funny because when
the you know when banks announce that
they can now
hold your crypto or i think it was the
u.s regulatory authorities sort of said
you know we give the green light for
this
i thought that was so funny i just
really did i thought it was hilarious um
but anyway so like i said we did have
celsius on a couple of weeks ago so
you know they are one of your main
competitors so for those that don't know
tell me how are you guys different to
them
yeah i mean look you know uh we see
celsius all the time
um you know to give you an idea of you
know where we sit we're
u.s based new york city uh new jersey
headquartered a lot of folks in new york
a lot of folks in in the in the u.s
we've got offices across five different
countries 350 employees
um we're regulated uh at the federal
level
uh money services business license and
then we're regulated at the state level
money transmitter licenses
as well as lending licenses in every
state that we operate in
um we never launched an ico
we don't have a utility token we've
raised all our money from
institutional capital folks like
susquehanna
peter thiel coinbase ventures the
winklevoss
about 100 million to date uh series c
was 50 million
and that's what the funds that we use to
operate our business
and so then you know because we don't
have a utility token
right all the yield that's generated to
pay our clients is directly correlated
to
the institutional demand that we have on
the lending portfolio on that side of
the house
um uh so that i would say the few things
there
are a little bit different yeah the
utility token is a huge one um you know
particularly
when it comes to earning that interest
and getting it back so
do you ever have any plans to get to
sort of launch utility token
we don't have any plans no not not to my
knowledge um
if anything we are firm believers in
stable coin
uh and that you know this market will
actually be
it will grow exponentially by
sheer nature of being able to interact
and pay with stable coins so
um more stable coin adoption more
currency adoption would be
kind of the first angle we would take if
any if anything for next year
okay so i want to kind of go into the
questions that was submitted those are
just a couple ones that were just off
the top of my head that
um i wanted to check with you guys but
um in terms of tax because tax is such a
huge issue when it comes to crypto and
it has this sort of
um you know negative dirty connotation
particularly bitcoin you know people
think that it's all about um money
laundering and tax evasion and that's
obviously just not the case
um so one of the questions actually
submitted is will there be any
integration with tax services um
like coin tracker for example yeah it's
a great question um i've had a ton
of really unique conversations with a
lot of different
tax providers who are building great
solutions for this space
totally agree with you this is look an
area where
more investment more buying and selling
more taxable events
are going to lead to just tools that
need to be created to help
manage and monitor more taxable events i
also think that
as we grow and as we scale this industry
right there will be a bit more of a
microscope on what's happening within
our space and we want to make sure we're
doing everything compliantly
we want to make sure that we're doing
everything under the regulatory
framework that is correct
tax i believe is going to be a big part
of that we
do have plans to integrate with a tax
provider
um it's not you know fully launched yet
so i don't want to
name names um but we are going to also
be looking into building some
external reporting apis in you know the
early half of next year so that
anybody who's a block by customer that
uses a tax service
you know externally whichever country
they that supports them or that they
decide to use would be able to pull
their information in in real time
or at least close to real time um but as
of today
uh we are not live we will be live i
want to say in a couple weeks so stay
tuned for uh some of the news on our
website
okay that's great so it's coming
basically yeah it's coming
all right great so another question for
you guys is block five profitable yet
yeah so uh we as a business
right from a health perspective are uh
on a tear uh the the best way for me to
give you an idea of
where we sit i started five months ago
we were 150 employees
uh we were doing eight figures of
revenue
uh we had about 1.5 billion assets on
the platform
and bitcoin was trading at about 10k
five months ago today we're about 380
employees across five countries we've
got
nine figures of revenue three uh
point one i believe as of today billion
assets on the platform and bitcoins
trading almost at
all-time highs honestly it might
we might see history on this call right
now i don't i don't know that would be
that'd be pretty remarkable but do you
know what you're right
i actually i'm just going to jump in i
actually need to check the price of
bitcoin while we're here
we're we are we are approaching a
historical moment
in time um 19.3
it could happen on the cool if it does
then that is just great and we'll we'll
celebrate somehow you know i might have
to run and go
find a bottle of wine grab a drink or
something keep this back
we all need to celebrate and then uh
this just that's the floor for the for
the
you know next however many of years that
we hit all-time highs which i think will
be a very long time
oh i'm excited so we're getting actually
quite a few questions coming through so
i'll
i'll go i'll answer these ones first and
then i'll answer the ones coming through
um okay so here's an interesting one for
you why does it take so long to transfer
out so somebody actually told me that
they um that it took them 36 hours to
transfer i think it was usdc
to kraken so they said it's really easy
to get the money in but
they're struggling to get the money out
so that's a bit concerning what's going
on
yeah we have a couple resources on the
website that actually talk about
various specifics on when you withdraw
what time of day and when the funds are
going to land in your account
we have a hold period uh it's typically
before 5 pm
eastern so i think the 36 hour issue is
could be an outlayer but um there are
moments where folks deposit or withdraw
sorry withdraw
after five on a weekend you know
sometimes it's delayed in that capacity
but really shouldn't see anything in
that
uh of that length um and
you know all of our withdrawal
information is online um we also have
some fees
regarding withdrawals they're pretty low
25 cents
for usdc and gsd um even lower for
other cryptos but all that information
yeah is readily available i'm happy to
uh shoot some links over after this to
share with your community
okay that sounds great i think that's
probably the best thing to do then um
just check out those withdrawal times um
but look i would say you know at least
you're getting money out it's not
crashing
and everything is running smoothly um
because i think we're always seeing
whenever borons happen
certain companies seem to crash so it's
good that we're
you're staying afloat for the minute um
this one's interesting actually
because you know of course interest is a
huge one for you guys so
can't block if i actually add graphs and
stats so people can actually track their
development and see how things are going
yeah a hundred percent so um
i currently have the beta uh you know
blockfy account which is awesome
uh so i get to see all the cool stuff
that's coming out before
our clients do um but we are going to be
releasing market prices
so being able to see the pricing um
directly
in uh in the app which is huge and then
uh charting functionality performance
statistics
uh just being able to look at you know
hit performance over time
these are all things that are going to
be coming within the ui
come early next year what i would really
like
encourage anyone on here listening who's
interested in those types of statistics
is to
just dm block fi's in twitter handle
and throw your feedback in we love to
see customer feedback of what people
would think would be valuable
um what types of tools that they'd be
interested in using
um so if you have any ideas shoot them
over that's the best way for us to
prioritize what we build for our
community
yeah i think you know having these kind
of graphs are so important
especially when you're trying to because
we were chatting earlier before we went
live and we were sort of saying you know
when you're trying to convince people to
join crypto and join the revolution all
the stuff and if you're trying to show
them these interest rates like you know
saying about my brother i was trying to
show him these interest rates
it'll be fantastic to have that graph
and just be like look at my portfolio
look what's happened
um so yeah that's good and i think um
that's really great to hear that
you know the community can reach out to
you and sort of say oh i'd like to see
this or when's that coming
um so yeah i i think that's really
important um
i want to talk about insurance
and and things like that so let's start
with um credit forward so
how do you guys actually protect against
credit for type um instances
yeah i mean one of the main
principles and drivers of building our
business
when we as we built it in as we continue
to build is concept of risk management
right and risk management is really you
know how do we prevent
losses because at the end of the day
we're a financial services business
and we're in the business of making sure
people money is secure
safe and it appreciates over time right
um
our chief risk officer he is uh
comes from the equity derivatives world
so
he's built many businesses that have
zero losses
providing margin lending or lending
against portfolios of equities
right so it's very similar to the way
that our book works today
any of the loans that we originate on
the institutional side a majority of
them
are over collateralized meaning that if
a company wants to if an institution
wants to borrow usdc or gusd they have
to post collateral
bitcoin ethereum litecoin etc and we
have access to that and we have access
to
sell that collateral in the event that
something a price swings in one way or
the other
right so we're protected on that side on
top of that
our kyc and underwriting process is
quite rigorous for an institution that
wants to borrow from blockfy
we ask for financials bank statements we
ask for
everything that you would think of when
you're looking to get a loan as an
institution anywhere else
as well as aml and kyc materials that we
can make sure that these companies are
real
right and they're not fraudulent and
they don't have you know significant
issues
in the market with other potential uh
partners or
players or fintechs or crypto firms et
cetera right so i would say
the risk management layer on top of the
over collateralization of our
institutional loans
plus our rigorous underwriting and
ability to not even fund unless we have
all these details really really create a
solid barrier
right and a solid uh risk uh
profile for you know who we work with
and how we operate in this space
um i will say when uh we've seen five 25
price swings here at block fight just by
nature of us starting business 2017
march of this year was a huge swing
we've experienced
uh perfect performance for our customers
right meaning zero losses uh
on the book so you know it's a testament
to their this
our risk management team it's a
testament to security it's a testament
to building the business with
this you know margin component in mind
um
and you know it's something that we're
we're very proud of and that we want our
our customers to understand that their
their money is is willing to work and
be safe and low risk at block by
so with that all in mind you know every
day this is crypto this is still really
immature market
um companies are still very new every
day we hear you know
really reputable companies going bust or
whatever and or getting hacked or
ceos running off with keys and all that
fun stuff
um so in terms of insurance
what are you insured and also
how much are you insured up to what
happens
in a situation whereby number one you
can't pay enough interest that
or you can't pay the interest that you
know you guys promise or number two
um you just don't have the money to give
people back when they
you know when they want to take the
money um off your platform
bit like a bank run or something like
that sure um
so cup couple things in that question
i can dice apart the first
insurance so today blockfi does not have
direct insurance for our customers but
we do custody uh all our assets with
gemini and bitco
uh and gemiini and bitco do have
insurance plans um
i would refer to their websites to read
up a little bit more on
how big how much but it's important to
understand that
uh them as a custody provider uh you
know
best the business time tested in terms
of
losses in the concept of you know
will block if i never be able to pay me
my interest et cetera
um couple things to think about the
first is
over collateralization on the
institutional book right you have
institutional borrowers
that are driving all the yield on our
platform if
the price of bitcoin as an example
goes from 19k to 4k we have margin calls
built in
so that we actually can sell right that
bitcoin
to cover our retail clients interest
before it gets to a price that's going
to be unsustainable for our business
right very important to understand right
you're giving as an institution us
at the actual collateral and it's ours
right um and if something happens to the
price
or they run away and they disappear or
they go out of business or whatever it
is
we have that over collateralization
right which means
you know uh over a hundred percent of
the value of the loan
we have in the form of of assets so
that's a huge protection
huge some of the other players in the
space you guys have heard of that have
potentially or or have gone under um
under collateralization is probably
something that they
supported in majority meaning
the amount of crypto or collateral that
you give me right
uh is less than the amount of the loan
notional that i give you
right so if the price drops there's a
there's a piece in there that i don't i
don't have the ability to make up for
very very risky um in my mind personally
and our company thinks the same way um
lastly
you know if any catastrophic event were
to happen black swan
um you'd face block fight as a business
we've raised a hundred
million of equity um and you know we are
very very strong and healthy from a
balance sheet perspective so
um of anyone in the space of anywhere to
be we are the place
um from uh from a risk perspective
because we actually do have a question
i'm gonna put it up on the screen
um so what would happen to user funds if
block fight got hacked so that's kind of
a bit of a follow-up question if you can
answer that for us
yeah so i mean security measures first
of all
is something that we believe in
wholeheartedly just as high i would say
number two to risk management
um we recently hired the cso from uh
backed his name's adam healy he's built
a team of
dozens of security engineers and and
security professionals that come from
the likes of
kpmg deloitte uh but then other you know
crypto native firms
so uh from a hack perspective we're
well positioned right to to be uh
ahead of anything that might come to
fruition um
you know in the event that something
happened again i think got to go back to
this concept of
uh we do have a incredibly strong
balance sheet we're well positioned to
make sure that if something did happen
our customers would be
covered uh in the capacity that we can
cover them um
and that's really important i think
because you know
our our balance sheet is so powerful
right and our risk management system is
so
uh it operates with uh
i would say rigor uh and and
little flaw coupled right with the
security concept of in the security
aspect of
you know how we've built this this that
side of the house
it's a it's a very secure environment
for
in my capacity okay um i want to move on
a little bit
um and i want to talk about a potential
credit card so
is that on its way um and
with that in mind actually um something
like crypto.com you know they they
provide interest and they have a card
so do you guys see yourselves as a
competitor
or someone similar in that in that
respect
yeah man i love when the credit card
conversation gets brought up because
it's so exciting
um most of the folks who uh listen to
your show leia and
honestly block fight followers or not
you may have may not heard that
we are going to be launching a bitcoin
rewards
credit card
in q1 of of 2021
um and it's gonna be a visa card right
it's got a really sweet logo i'm not
gonna
tell anybody what it looks like quite
yet um and you're gonna be able to spend
um your credit card fiat at merchants
and earn one point five percent back in
bitcoin
that's good when it's going to get
deposited in your block by interest
account and your bitcoin's going to
start earning interest
as you receive it as you redeem
so we think that you know as a business
uh our
customers predominantly uh prefer to
hold their bitcoin and earn interest on
it versus spend it
so we figure why not spend fiat credit
and then have that credit get converted
into bitcoin rewards
so a lot of interesting demand and uh
excited to launch that
okay just a question on that fiat credit
then can you just clarify where's that
fiat money coming from so
how is that card getting topped up like
can we
go for it it's like any other credit
card that you would get at a bank
right it's uh it's created by our card
partner and then
you get a limit right say your limit's
five thousand bucks
you spend five thousand dollars worth of
credit via the bank that supports our
card
and then of that five thousand dollars
we multiply 1.5 at the end of the month
and you get that amount in bitcoin then
you just got to pay the card back like
you would any other card
in your wallet oh sorry i missed you so
it's a credit card
right it's not debit sorry sorry so
there's no topping up
um no topping up whatsoever you pay it
back yeah
yeah just just like your standard card
and i think it why did you choose that
option that's quite interesting
yeah i think it goes to like this
narrative that um you know we want to
bridge the gap between traditional
financial services and crypto
right and i think uh being able to use
a credit or for like a form of payment
in the form of credit and earn bitcoin
back is a really good way to
enter the market for a lot of people um
and it's also a good way to
you know earn an asset that you don't
necessarily want to spend
some people don't want to spend their
bitcoin yeah i think that's interesting
um
um i'll definitely try that out i'd like
to try everything out um
i'm a big fan of of crypto cards um i
think i have like
three which is actually too many if you
think about it actually there's actually
too many and i kind of want to try more
to be honest so i'll definitely give
that a go
we've got some uh some great news coming
out on uh
next week you'll see uh around a
waitlist and uh you'll be able to see
what the card looks like it i think when
you see it you're gonna want it
and to have it and use it because that
matters right like on a really
shallow level that matters you know it's
like i wanna i wanna go to a restaurant
and drop my you know block fight card on
the table
you know and is it plastic or is it
going to be metal can we just can we get
that info
yeah we're we're debating i think a
beginning run will be
there'll be like a limited time offer of
metal and then
we might uh you know be a different
material but still in the works
um all of that yeah like if you join the
wait list
and you move up on the waitlist by
referring people you get
a chance to get the medal card so that's
a nice
perk there you go um which if any assets
will be added so i actually don't know
what are you missing right now which
assets don't you have
yeah you know i this is a this is a
great question because
so many people write in and so many
folks ask us about
borrowing in certain assets and then
also just earning yield on a lot of
assets i think you're going to see
you know between two and five new assets
get added to block fi
by the end of q1 of 2021
those assets are going to be assets that
have uh that predominantly been in the
top 10 market cap if not top 20.
um okay and and mostly all
existing you know have been around for
you know
the last handful of years and have some
significant market cap to them so
yeah makes sense okay so here's a
question um specifically from me
um so given bitcoin is just running
right now
my dms are flooded my dm's are just like
wow can i get in where can i get in no
no no no no
all that fun stuff um so you know my
i have quite a few favorite platforms
and you know i think you guys are a
reputable company so you're one of the
people that i would like to suggest but
i can't
because you don't allow people to
actually buy crypto
with fiat right so i know that you can
buy let's say bitcoin with um
usdt but that's unhelpful for those who
don't have any crypto whatsoever they
don't have stable coins
so when are you actually going to
provide going to provide some actual
serious direct on-wraps and off-ramps
actually
yeah so the way that our on-ramps work
today and i can explain it
um it's actually very simple and
straightforward so
uh we have one method of moving fiat
onto
uh the platform that's via a wire so you
can wire your
local fiat directly from your bank
account
into your block by interest account and
that will purchase
usdt if you're you know abroad or it
will purchase gusd or usdc
depending on what you want to select um
let's say
ten thousand dollars you wire into the
platform just for example purposes
uh you will have a balance of 10 000
gusd
in like two hours right because wires
move pretty quickly
yeah as soon as you have that balance in
your platform you've deposited those
funds and converted to gusd
you could buy bitcoin immediately but do
you have to convert it to gsd or were
you saying that as soon as you wire it
it's automatically done or you actually
have to do that today you have to
wire in for gusd and then go in and
purchase the bitcoin
um we all also are
releasing actually today the ability to
ach funds
onto the platform as well in the same
capacity which is a little bit easier
than wiring
right because with ach all you do is
just connect your bank account
uh and then that's it you can push money
on whatever you want takes
i think two to three business days to
land um
but yeah in the future there will be the
ability to just directly buy it have
that have that kind of like conversion
piece the
gusd to bitcoin piece happen instantly
today though it's just wire in log in
buy bitcoin now you own bitcoin you're
immediately earning interest on that
bitcoin
six percent is what we pay today but i
just want to clarify because maybe i'm
not getting it maybe i'm being
ridiculous but
when you wire in your fear are you
saying that
it automatically lands in gusd it
automatically lands in whichever you
sell whichever stable coin you select
yeah oh usdc usdt if you're abroad
and what's cool about the wire and the
automatic land is as soon as that
those funds land in your account and are
converted to stablecoin
you earn 8.6 on stablecoin on our
platform
right well there you go so your money's
always earning interest no matter where
it is on block fi
which is really cool okay so just
finally because we're approaching half
an hour to wrap up our ama
um what is gonna look like
for you guys what is going on um it's
been a wild year
um everything with the coronavirus it
seems that it hasn't really affected our
industry that much
given how decentralized everything is so
that's really great um but yeah
with that in mind you know we don't know
what's going on with the korean virus in
what does 2021 look like for you guys um
any new
updates coming i know you mentioned the
card and so on
yeah i mean we've got a ton of new
really big important hires we're
bringing on a new cfo
um in the end of this month uh we're
probably going to double the team next
year just
based by sheer uh you know hiring
needs and where we're adding folks
already it's
pretty remarkable we'll be launching
some new products
more specifically enhancing right
trading functionality
enhancing some of the visualizations on
the ui enhancing some of the onboarding
and fiat on ramps as well as you just
mentioned leia
and then really focusing a lot of our
efforts on
the credit card because we really do
think this credit card could be
you know a huge uh push for
the industry bringing on you know
traditionally crypto curious folks who
are now
you know using a card and earning
bitcoin um and there's just
you know so many cool avenues of of
partnerships exploration bd growth that
you can do with something along those
lines but
um i'm really looking forward to 2021. i
think
the crypto market is only going to go up
and to the right the amount of adoption
that we've seen is
unbelievable institutional and retail as
you've seen it as well
um yeah i i joke with with my girlfriend
like she's like constantly asking me
what i'm doing on my phone and i say
i'm reading crypto twitter i can't get
out of it
it's addictive there's too much good
hype it's uh
it's too exciting it's too funny the
memes are too good the new number yeah
yeah exactly yeah i encourage anybody
who's uh listening
during thanksgiving if they have uh you
know or or holidays
wherever you are if you're with the
family and you're talking about bitcoin
to uh
to help uh educate them the best way you
can i've already had to have a couple
educating conversations
there you go that's so funny yeah i mean
it is crazy the amount of people that
we're seeing getting it getting into
bitcoin i think
just recently within an hour the other
day i think 25 000 new bitcoin addresses
were made in one hour
which is the highest since the previous
bull run
yeah yeah so yeah i'm so excited um
but yeah shane i want to thank you so
much it's been really great um hearing
all of this um
doing the ama with you so thank you so
much for coming on awesome lay i really
appreciate it thanks for being a great
partner as well
yeah absolutely pleasure guys definitely
don't forget to tune in on thursday
because i have a really cool guest i'll
tell you now
cz is coming on the show so it's going
to be so much fun guys
so make sure you tune in on thursday it
will be at 12
p.m est so i will see you all then bye
[Music]
[Applause]
bye